mitchell trubisky will well who knows
what's gonna happen with the quarterback
position they still got nick foles under
contract mitch trubisky is a free agent
they may keep him he may be the one that
they decide after looking at late season
film maybe he's our best option
that's the question for the chicago
bears above all others who will the
quarterback
be
they were never really in the carson
wentz thing because carson wentz didn't
want to go there so they need to find
somebody one who's available and two
wants to be there i don't know who that
is chris i don't know who that is either
mike i mean it's it's that's it's a big
one it really is
first off
yeah i i mean trubisky the way they
played
everything like that do i think they can
win with trubisky yeah i do you know but
i don't know is the city going to accept
that back do they still want to see that
is going to be tremendous pressure on
that
you know is matt nagy going to change
and change the way he plays are they
going to be that team that we saw you
know towards the end of the year i think
those are all big questions i mean i of
course we know they're looking for an
upgrade at that position there's no
doubt but who is that going to be i
don't know are they laying in the weeds
or maybe to see what happens with the
jets and sam darnold in that situation
that's certainly there but i think at
the very least like you know they're not
going to get to sean watson we know that
i don't think they're getting russell
wilson and honestly i think a lot of the
like if those guys were named to be
there they're going to look at that and
go wait i don't know if i want to go
play in that offense that offense is
just it's been extremely underwhelming
extremely underwhelming so they got to
get that situation figured out let alone
to go with that the offensive line i
mean those are the two biggest areas on
their football team and they go hand in
hand with the success of the offense
the the problem i think for any
quarterback who has the opportunity to
be the starter for the bears is that the
message that ultimately came from the
team after the season a lot like the
message that came from the lions last
year we're sticking with the guys we
have
but it feels like it's a proven
situation so who's the pressure on the
new guy coming through the door the new
quarterback he's trying to save jobs
because if it all goes to hell
everyone's going to be gone and then if
you sign a multi-year contract as the
quarterback you're in a situation where
after one year there may be a new gm
there may be a new head coach
i've just moved to chicago i made the
commitment and they're done with me with
the new regime so i think that's going
to make guys who have options reluctant
i'm still fascinated by the possibility
of alex smith reunion with matt nagy
time together in kansas city configure
the offense for him but i think at the
end of the day it's maybe maybe it's
trubisky backed up by alex smith maybe
that's the answer well i i i i would it
could be i don't have an issue with that
i don't you know
like i kind of said that you know when i
was on some stations there in chicago
towards the end of the year i mean
they're closer to the top than they are
at the bottom so you better be careful
about abandoning ship and doing all of
that and i do think trubisky got his
confidence back a little bit towards the
end of the year he did do some good
things there's no doubt about that and
if they can play a certain way and use
his athleticism in the run game and boo
legs and all that and and really build
around that aspect of his game
you know again yes i do think they can
win i mean i'm
it was only what two years ago or it was
three years ago he drove them down
divisional playoff game
i mean our wild card game right it was a
wild card game drove them down to make a
very
easy winnable field goal kick and they
didn't come through so it's not like
he's the worst thing in the world if you
give them some support this team has a
lot of key pieces i mean
can they resign allen robinson i don't
know does he want to go back there i
don't know he's a really good player i
don't look at their offense
having you know tremendous roster issues
i don't i just think they got to fix
that old line and they got to figure out
that quarterback situation and of course
their defense is damn good too
and what did we talk about an hour ago
the psychology of a team in the
offseason as it relates to looking at
what went right looking at what went
wrong how we can build on the success we
had so for the bears right now as
they're breaking down what happened in
2020
they may be warming up to the idea of
mitch trubisky the challenge is getting
the fans to warm up to it too i think
the fans are wired to reject anything
that the team does yeah anything unless
unless they can can somehow get desean
watson which isn't happening or russell
wilson which isn't happening or go back
in time and take patrick mahomes
when they could have taken him instead
of trubisky
the fans are not going to be placated by
anything they do and i think the
organization just needs to understand
we're going to take a hit no matter what
our move is let's make the move that we
think is right and then when we win
games in september and october they'll
shut the hell up about it yeah i i mean
you're right they're going to be critic
unless they bring a superstar and you're
right they're going to be critical no
matter what because there's a sense
there that this this regime can't
evaluate quarterbacks so they're going
to have to deal with that stigma and
especially with nick foles not working
and all of that to me it's less about
the quarterbacks and more about the
offense i mean we saw that they finally
adjusted a little at the end of the year
and stopped trying to you know squish
the the round peg into the square hole
that that was a big thing uh and the way
they played towards the end of the year
finally help their defense out too i
mean their defense is damn good they
don't need a whole lot on the defensive
side of the ball i mean really
they need more out of guys like robert
quinn who they paid a lot of money and
he didn't do anything last year khalil
mack is very good but not been the
superstar that i think they were hoping
for
and and and don't forget this aspect too
they didn't have one of the best nose
tackles in football last year because of
the covet opt out eddie goldman is one
of the best interior defensive lineman
in all of football you add him to the
mix with akeem hicks and those two guys
we just talked about on the edge and
then trevathon and roquan smith in the
middle damn i'll take i'll put that
front seven up there just about against
anybody
secondary with eddie jackson and fuller
you know there's there's enough there to
go around to go it's pretty good yeah
maybe a little you know polish here and
there but i don't think it's a team
that's incredibly far off but they got
to figure out how they're going to play
on offense according to who their
quarterback is and the big thing is i
think more than anything on their team
is you know quarterback and offensive
line they got to fix that damn offensive
line there in chicago
yeah i agree with you they have a lot
that they need to do to get back to
where they were last year they got to
the playoffs
and and they've got other teams in the
division that are trying to catch up to
them
anybody oh as i say anybody out there
else at quarterback that you think of
that's
you know a possibility right i i i don't
i mean nothing excites me as i think
about it i don't know you know i really
don't the one i do look at is that new
york jet situation and what they do and
are they gonna take a quarter like
listen if they put sam donald on the
market
you know that's telling everybody oh
they're drafting a quarterback at two
and i wouldn't think you'd have to trade
the farm to get sam darnold i mean
there's certainly questions there
and he's had he has been injured and
with them putting on the market they're
basically telling you they don't want
him so that lessens his value too i mean
that's one that jumps out to me that
really does other than that i i can't i
mean there's not a free agent out there
that i think oh that moves the needle
that
so
i'm interested to see how this plays out
for them at this position and bears fans
won't be happy with sam darnold they
won't be happy with anyone so make the
best decision that you think is going to
result in wins right out of the gates
that is the only way to get the fans in
chicago behind what the bears do at
quarterback they're going to have to
prove it with whoever they decide to go
with
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports